[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this playing policy
subcommittee meeting before we get into
the text of the meeting and the agenda I
need to make a couple of announcements
one is the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit one there one there there
are two fire escapes in the room if you
need to evacuate the room by the door
the fire escape staircase please hold
both handrails in case the stairs are
wet or slippery if anyone is able to use
the stairs would they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire exit door where they can be
given assistance please do not use the
lift our assembly point will be in the
public carpark at this side of the Civic
suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect your belongings
please do not return to the building and
to have been given permission to do so
far council staff please note this
meeting will be audio recorded before we
move on with the the main body of the
agenda I think I it would be appropriate
at this time to highlight a very large
vacancy that we have on this committee
one of our old colleagues Chris black
died recently as you may well be aware
and although Chris was very passionate
about virtually everything that he was
involved with to do with the district
and he's in his ward
I think planning was always very close
to his heart and his input into this
probe process will be sadly missed so if
you wouldn't mind I think we should just
spend a minute standing in silence if
you can stand to acknowledge what Chris
is done for our board and for this
committee for the planning and putting a
district and it's rose
as a whole thank you
thank you very much
can I just point out I will introduce
the members of the committee and the
officers here for the benefit of our
visitors today
excuse me this is a planning policy
subcommittee is held in public body is
not a public meeting
therefore I'm afraid visitors are not
allowed to contribute towards the
process questions will be asked like
committee members and I'm sure that if
you don't got anything you would have
contacted them already
apologies representative in my place
Sonia and counselor mrs. Hills and
substitutes please we have a councillor
Ward substituting for cancer in your
honor and we have cancer a hook we're
substituting for callousness this year
fine thank you very much and donít
members attending for the benefit of our
our visitors here today I will introduce
our officers and our committee members
substitute going from my left is Ian
Ward Sean scram who's amazing director
of Rochford District Council Sonia
Worthington who is at Democratic
Services Officer my name is Dave
spurring this is Matthew Thomas who is
the ad for planning and regeneration
Natalie Haywood who is the team leader
for planning policy and economic
development and Dan Goodman who is the
policy planner the other committee
members here as you've heard is has the
hook way who's substituted for counter
hughes counsel John Mason and councillor
German rambling
but one more chair okay
coming sir
okay right item number four on our
agenda is to receive minutes of the
meeting held in the 28th of November
which have recently been circulated to
all members of stand in agreement with
what you can remember members agreed
thank you very much
to receive declarations of interest okay
thank you now we get on to the real nuts
and bolts of this this meeting Maya
suggests that item six in item seven are
the main areas for comment contribution
and that items 8 to 15 inclusive are
really evidence based documents we'll go
through every one of these individually
with mr. Thomas making some comments
before a brief appraisal of each item
and then we will return as they're all
contributing factors to item 6 and 7 we
will return to them because they will be
evidence based documents if that's okay
remembers okay okay let's go on to item
number eight then which is the new local
plan issues and options documents tragic
housing and employment land availability
assessment known as the sheeter 2017 who
are you I'm just gonna cross over to my
team yep flying planning policy is to
give the brief outline and the documents
tonight okay thank you okay so I'll just
use the abbreviation machine they're
just fat free it is quite a key
to engage with landowners to represent
all the teachers desire to find out the
potential of a divinity of land is in
the district and then as a local
property to do a more specific
assessment on it in terms of the the
planning practice guidance more detail
on the national park on how we should
undertake this assessment so we have
done the majority of the work in-house
the availability of land is informed by
a call for sites which are huge in 2015
we also did some desktop research based
on some past evidence on potential labs
that might be available for example in
this is the residential area we also did
a review of the council own land assets
right across the district as well so
these are the three key areas which have
informed the assessment availability of
land also had an independent viability
assessment done of all the sites that
have been assessed
there's 219 in total so it's quite
expensive job
and in terms of the suitability our
evidence space in its entirety still we
still have different work on that
particular around these strengths and
this does include the Greenbelt
assessment we haven't done that as yet
so in terms of the suitability the the
Sheila itself can't make any firm
recommendations on whether the vast
majority of sites that was put forward
are actually suitable because the bottom
jority
are if you've had a look at that
document are actually currently
allocated to us without land board
outcome the assessment is that there are
38 sites which are potentially suitable
available and deliverables these off
don't lay within the existing
residential area already and they they
are both brown food and the sheena
itself is only an evidence-based
document it doesn't allocate sites and
it is not Plan C so it's clearly his
purpose is just to give us a baseline of
where there may or may not be
potentially suitable lands that we we
could consider in the future and at this
point in time it doesn't make
thank you John
thank you Jim I'm not taking a very very
very deep breath because I think this is
the document which is alarmed most
residents that have seen it or heard
about it which is why I guess other
people are here I recognize a lot of you
I think I know where you've come from
and I'm not surprised looking at the
maps that you have concern I was alarmed
as well
but then I did have the benefit of
greater knowledge of the process that
the count's was going through to greater
local plan indeed with Chris black I
remember collaborating with him in 2006
on the last one so with that it gives me
some assurances to what's actually going
on it is as the officers say a
reflection of agents and landowners who
put their land forward for consideration
and I am assured by the previous process
in this one that there are no pre
conditions no pre selection that has
taken place on behalf of the council
somebody did this for me I wrote to me
so I haven't checked it myself so maybe
officers might might help me the figure
of 993 I know they've quoted because
that figure seems to be the number of
dwellings that are already zoned in
Levin land in this she look shall our
call he would earn your money and though
they're in residential notation already
I think someone wrote to me and said
there were 24,000 potential to Hemmings
in the remainder of the sites were
forward so that's struck me as being 20
5,000 but of course that will alarm
residents usually it alarms me frankly
it isn't possible and it's not even what
we're even asked to consider my own
opinion and we'll come back to this
later because we've taken things in a
slightly different order and I did raise
this the other afternoon is that I think
that is not a target
I recognize that mr. Thomas responded to
me the other afternoon by saying is not
a target but with shortfalls from 2011
from relation back and shortfalls but
going back to 2014 that the methodology
the oen requires that with those two
shortfalls and with 12 years at the high
end figure which is 361 I calculate it
as something like a figure of 7500 but
that of course is the figure which is in
the parlance in the technical by opening
it unconstrained that means that that is
a figure which is being created by the
methodology put forward by the
government and has been carried out on
many councils perhaps as part of the
previous Thames gateway to come up with
what is called a strategic market
assessment so we're talking about
figures that have been assessed in
accordance with methodologies they
haven't been tested against the evidence
and that is something that the Chairman
true to your attention at the very
beginning because it's the evidence that
determines whether that number is anyway
deliverable so you need everyone needs
to engage with their evidence yep and
I've got a great deal more to say about
that evidence probably legs if I'm going
to say now to him if I may he because I
think it sets the scene yet right well
we need as a council as members
as as communities we need to look at
evidence and we need to challenge it we
need to understand what it says and even
though it's been produced by very
technically abled people including our
own there are obviously things that have
requirements for improvement and I
believe that the issues of
infrastructure the issues of environment
the issues of economic ambition are
probably the most important ones for us
to challenge and I'm going to say that I
don't think there's any rush we're not a
council that's ended up on site Joby's
list
he's been published today the council
points sonic buzzards and sonic
Brentwood's on it they haven't produced
a plan at all we have produced them and
he was running so there is no rush for
this council to rush into another 20
years without having considered and
challenged the evidence and the
organizations to produce it very
robustly so I'm going to say later you
might think 2021 is a generous target I
don't mind if it goes on longer
providing we're challenging the evidence
and making the right decisions for the
out communities in this district
chairman our risk there needed to be a
speaking event people took off that's my
view on where we've started okay do you
want to come back Matthew on on that or
an essay or brief comment you have to
say that the place to challenge the
evidence is through representations on
the issues and options and further
stages of the local plan just to say
that okay yes yes it is an opportunity
through further consultation for
stakeholders residents and others to
challenge but I'd also like to see
councilman Charlie
yeah counselors didn't challenge last
time except in isolated wards which I
was one I'm not sure there's many people
around from those days but I believe all
counselors should look significantly at
all of the evidence and challenge it
particularly in the awards so as a
collective you thank you for that Neil
and yeah just to follow on from that
what would seem to be quite generous
period of public consultation of 12
weeks I think in reality when you have
to look at how some of the bodies that
may be involved in this operate it may
not be quite so generous for them an
example of parish councils especially
those that only meet every six weeks and
that's halfway through a potential
consultation period if that doesn't fall
in the right way for for that parish
council so we want the engagement of
important bodies like parishes and stuff
like that we might need to consider as
to whether the 12-week period is
sufficient I think I would be inclined
to say excuse me the 12-week period will
be the 12-week period will push the
information out to the parishes as soon
as we can there's no reason why a parish
or town council can't call an emergency
meeting to discuss the options they can
do it in week one they could do it in
week two they can have three meetings in
that twelve and if that's the parishes I
feel to dictate their priority on this
there's no reason if you say so
every six weeks I pointed at one for a
fortnight it's a big issue when we know
that so that would be in my view I think
you know I think the point you'd make
Jonah okay lot more quiet values what
concerns me is having heard the news
yesterday of the government's directive
we could be looking in the
not-too-distant future a whole new set
of criteria that we've got to comply
with so we plow on with this lot as it
is today and see what the government's
directive is after the budget next week
because we may be looking at other
issues
can I just come here sure I recognize
what you say I I know the government is
consulting on changes the mtbf and more
particularly the the methodology for
assessing original numbers of which
represent lead having said that there's
no reason why this council as a whole
know notwithstanding the the political
makeup can't change the government and
there's no need for us like other
councils to rush in to two sets of
figures which we're not we're not
confident about okay I I don't have a
problem with any of this John I think we
all want to do the best we can for a for
the district to have for our residents
we do however have a recommendation that
we have to put the full Council which is
it is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves that the strategic housing
employment land availability assessment
on the attached at appendix be noted as
evidence and published in the councils
website
do we agree with that yes yeah tell me I
agree Deb if the evidence has been
produced yeah in accordance with the the
way the government the mtbf and other
guiding guiding principles require us to
do yep so we also know close I know in
the in the document and our offices I
don't know which one but recommend that
this is something it's revisited at
least annually I agree about it and it's
going to be very necessary for I think
it's going to be important for residents
action groups residents groups whatever
not to get too alarmed about about the
mass well I think they've got to do is
look at the pieces of lands that have
been put forward and although there's
been a rudimentary sustainability
analysis done officers are already
concluded and admitted that it's it's
only the back of it sorry it's about
going in
and I'd say that there are many informed
residents out there who could could
answer that and I don't see any reason
why any consultation they shouldn't look
at individual sites and bearing in mind
their local knowledge shouldn't comment
on whether they think there's
sustainable opportunities or not I'm
sure you're taken on board
yeah absolutely with me representations
I would say you know at this stage it's
it's an issue assumptions document
there's no allocated sites no proposed
sites when those do come forward in the
future obviously there's opportunity to
comment on those but yes if there's some
knowledge of existing sites that will
help the early process then that min
that's on issue
jadynn yes it's not just my ayat you
know I agree with a lot of the items
that Thomas actually put forward I feel
it's just vitally important that the
whole community really do look at what's
going on and engage at the earliest
possible time so that they have an
opportunity to put in what they feel is
necessary within their own communities
you know we do have rules that we do
have to abide by but it's still very
very important to have that engagement
with the communities where we went out
to the parishes to get their views and
that needs to be online this needs to be
a consultation the whole way through Jim
okay thank you that's one what yeah I'm
sure there'll be plenty of opportunity
for people to make their views known we
got quite a lengthy agenda to go through
and I think we could we've got a crack
on with this moving on to item number 9
which is the new low so I am just yes
the brief little statement is young this
is a process where everything including
the kitchen sink is rowing in and I
think there's a benefit for that because
what was brought up at a previous
training session was in relation to
windfall development and we want to try
and encompass everything so that we've
done those incomes - yes yeah so that we
don't miss out on some knowledge or a
windfall sites going forward I think I
think it's you know I can say we're all
going in the same direction this I don't
think there's anybody trying to pull it
in various directions
it's our district we all live here we
want to do the best we can for the
district and for our residents some of
us appear longer than others but we'll
crack in in a few years now moving on to
item number 9 before it which is the new
local plan issues not finished document
economic development needs topic paper
2017 Leslie
fifteen to twenty years it is settled in
the context of South Essex but wasn't
available at the time we paper is a lot
easier to digest South physics
assessment itself it does indicate that
we're looking at a minimum of seven
hectares of new employment labs up to
2036 these there is a range of up to 16
hectares but that also includes issues
of loss of traditional industrial uses
on existing employment sites for leather
uses for example for example there is a
little bit more work that we need to do
ourselves to work out how much long
actually do need to provide to deliver
the number of jobs to support any new
housing that comes through over the next
20 years
so we're looking at somewhere in the
range of between seven and 16 hectares
of new employment land
ok any questions jump in on the on this
one yes job I think I think Natalie
Hayward absolutely right this is just
the beginning that's what I was
referring to a little earlier by saying
is this this is the sort of evidence
that he's going to develop and it
doesn't stop here I think this is only
going to come come further to the fore
and does need with the most imp the most
important scrutiny and and challenge to
ensure that we we get the distribution
of new employment sites exactly right in
the right place with the right sort of
employment that's going to be supported
by the infrastructure we have which we
already have concerns about how it
supports the housing it also has to
support industry new in the nearing
employment opportunity
yeah and I think that's something we
haven't done we need to do I get the
feeling there's got to be more
partnership here I get the feeling that
you know I'd like some real world I
think when we embarked on and there are
people here who would agree with them
weren't the Hopley era action plan which
required a an industrial site to be
vacated and moved elsewhere which in
itself hasn't happened it hasn't
happened significantly and probably
won't the lots of really reasons as well
but it was also because the money main
the just weren't involved enough and I
think but we've got to do more work and
we've got to get a real wording real
world engagement so that what does come
forward isn't some wish list ambition
but represents a real thing because
there's nothing like a plan that
actually stands a chance of happening
the worst sort of plan doesn't happen
and that's what we have in a number of
parts of our existing core strategy
so my recommendation chairman is to
accept it because it's what we've got at
the moment but it ain't enough for me no
I don't clean Joe and it Bob we've had
this conversation over on many various
formats that you know this is the start
and we will all work in the same
direction we've got to do the best we
can for the residents and our district
with the constraints that will be
imposed on us and they could be
substantial in the years to come you
understand now I know that but we do the
best we can I don't think we could do
any more like accept there will be more
partnership working at Leena's fairly
obvious whether it just be between money
men or other districts
we'll have to see other councillors item
number 9 then the recommendation is
proposed that the economic development
needs topic paper 2017 as attached to
the appendix I be noted as evidence and
published on the council's website ok ok
thank you
moving on to item number 10 there which
is the new local playing issues and
options document retail and leisure
needs topic paper 2017
and again this follows along similar
lines as li economic topic paper the
retail and leisure study has been done
again in South Wessex level
unfortunately it hasn't been finalized
in time to when we welcome to publish
the evidence valuation option so again
we have produced a specific topic
profile which sets out the search
requirements for retailers uses in the
district off into the 2030s the topic
paper looks at the expenditure and
leakage in and out of these districts
how we relate to other areas in
southwest it's where dreams are and it
identifiers what we could essentially do
to reduce that okay any questions on
this one Neal its potential firms sort
of like retail so you've changed quite
dramatically over this period with the
rise of electronic like sales and stuff
like that and presuming that you've been
fully assessed on how that may have an
impact on their town centre yeah
absolutely and the pleasure in spending
patterns that are currently sort of seen
in the districts are taken into account
and there are projections on how that's
like to change in the future
it does consider how the big operators
in particular are functioning at the
moment and it does kind of conclude that
those those retailers that have
basically moved with the times the
quickest of the most successful nodes of
the ones that we still see in our
Townsend
and they offer they're not looking at
the generally look at the larger format
stores anymore but they are still
opening smaller stores but they offer
that full range of services where you do
you click and Collect you can order if
you can do the full range of full range
of shopping as well as viewing those
products in store as well okay Joe given
Kevin this is the one where I would like
to see what residents will see there's
their retail needs yeah and leisure
needs over the next 20 years there's a
lot to be said for the retailers and
their providers actually following what
residents want rather than just actually
coming up of what they want to give so I
think this is a great opportunity a very
slim document but I think appealing for
residents to give their wider views on
their retail and leisure needs over the
next 20 years
their vision would be very appropriate
there's a lot of opportunity yep
Matthew and again just highlight to
everyone here and obviously you know
during the the consultation process too
if they do have a particular interest in
these areas to respond to those areas of
the local plan issues and actions
consultation okay if I'm just yeah I
think it's probably very very important
that where we have retail where we have
any economic development it's a case of
if you don't use it you lose it and it's
all based on the needs that precede me I
can understand what John is saying with
regard to the response from residents
but whatever residents wants they're
going to have to come make sure is what
they want and they will use it because
unfortunately developers won't come into
an area if they feel that they can't
economically
yeah because the because the study
doesn't look happy
the Southwest six level it looks up the
the bigger picture earlier where the
drawers Arkansan example cinema
provision yeah so it looks at what the
capacity were the likely capacities of
the district to retaining that
expenditure within it within the area
itself rather than people going
elsewhere to the recommendation again on
this one is that the retail and leisure
needs typing paper 2017 as attached to
the appendix I be noted and evidence
published on the council's website food
moving on to item number eleven which I
think we've had some experience of
recently is the new local plan issues
not given up options document duty to
cooperate topic paper 2017 eukaryote
Natalie at Boeing so as many members
will be aware the Jewish cooperate was
formalized in the Localism Act in 2011
and this requires us to cooperate engage
with various bodies including our
neighboring local authorities on any
strategic cross boundary issues this can
include housing jobs infrastructure
anything that's of that's going on that
level of groups between different
it is a legal requirement and it's
something that once a plan gets to the
submissions data for a planning aspect
of examination it's the first point that
the planning inspector will look at how
the you complied of duty call freight
throughout the plan making process it's
not something that you can make good at
the end of the process after you have
submitted so it's very important that as
electrifying authority we do this
throughout the planning process at each
stage will just emphasize the thing
nicely it's not only a question of other
people looking at our plans but us
watching their plans which i think was
quite appropriate with castle point when
they just tried to upload to fails not
houses to the surrounding district John
and then this is this is very topical
yeah
so I Jabby really do secretary
community's secretary gave a speech
yesterday and he says he'd lost patience
with councils that have failed to do
anything about a local plan and he is
required he requires resident council
point and Greg wood to provide an
explanation by the 31st of January and
he's only making plans and there wasn't
the only council's there were sixteen or
seventeen other ones from around the
country looking York and other place so
they Southeast exorcisms alone but it
stands out quite quite badly
he's already considering what and what
plans he process he will put in place a
takeover it's as simple as that
that alarms me hugely because although
these councils have been slumbering
along and instead of building houses the
way we've been planning to do they've
done absolutely nothing I kind of fear
that they're now going to rush because
they're required to rush
I'm not sure how they're going to have
the time to look at constraints I wonder
what happens after that
doo doo castle point continue with
somebody else is going to have to use
their green belt these bars will be
really going to you know step up with
all of its political changes who knows
Greenwood well Bretton Woods almost and
I'm sure your Brentwood I understand
it's a bit of as a bit of gamesmanship
being played between between districts
so this is this is important because
we're facing this oen my estimate of 7
are thousands before constraint I'd hate
to see substantial numbers come across
from other districts though frankly have
done very little yeah to contribute to
softening if not delivering to the
housing crisis because there is one it
looks to me when the army people are
doing it now that's a good thing and a
bad thing but I'm concerned I think what
you want to come back might be I think
the comments that we made and and when
we had to the Inspectorate with December
with Castle Kuwait off 12th of December
I think you know our officers were on
the ball we made our case and the
Inspectorate
supported the comments and they
basically cast a point we're told to go
back and revisit their plan as far as
long as have to govern math you know I
cancel Mason so it's very valid here and
that's why sort of under the duty to
cooperate ethics authorities have been
meeting we have a memorandum of
understanding but it comes back to the
evidence base again and as cancer Mason
as mentioned we are ahead of the game
because we have we've started to get
everything in line as far as what we
need to demonstrate to show what we are
able to take or not take and what we
able to deliver in this authority other
authorities will have to do the same if
their evidence base isn't up to scratch
and
that's been used a lot is no stone
unturned and that is looking at full
capacity and then understanding your
constraints against your potential
delivery so here in Rochford we we are
doing absolutely what it's necessary
others haven't and as others haven't
it's difficult for them to then ask us
to look at their need until they have
actually looked in full at their own
need so I feel that we're in a
particularly good position but we're
working well across South Essex as I say
we have a memorandum of understanding
and the strategic issues are being
discussed at this point okay thank you
Castle nice is correct in saying about
how topical this is barely mine was in
the news yesterday I think it also
highlights the the the issue to their
residents and the general public that
the central government is is key in this
whole process because ultimately the
rules of the game is set by central
government and we are playing the game
by those rules
and if the rules change it's not
anything that we've done it's what's
happened somewhere else in Acts of
Parliament etc so those changes that we
then have to take into consideration
it's normally you know changes that
happen in another place that we have to
we have to do so I think I think you're
right now but I think there's Matthew
said you know at the moment we've got
the high ground we've done our stuff
with we're we're set up we know where
we're going we know what we've got to do
and we can address other people's issues
because we put ourselves in this
position they unless central government
policy however dictates there's a
substantial change we think that we're
strong enough and
located well enough to deal with should
we say imposed issues potentially from
other districts on us whether the
inspector and the government in due
course have a different view on that
then we'll have to address but the
moment I think we're in a pretty good
place as a as a district John I didn't
get my point
oh well that's okay but I did welcome
what you know mr. Thomas had to say I
think I'm concerned that if there is a
project manager put in by the DC og into
Castle point at least if not Basile
communities at least coming up to its
section 19 consultation anyway and
Brentwood which seems to be moving on
even if they're not involved I kind of
fear that a project management of ecog
might at the very least take the least
line of resistance and say well you know
you don't seem to have done very well
whatever counsel he's in I've got to be
careful and you know you haven't got the
evidence but I'd a more need to have
these houses built because I Germans
told me so
Bradford's got this sorted out so Rochet
yours so that's why that's my concern I
think my concern is an imperative from
government may just simply look at a
council that isn't or in a district that
isn't well prepared saying well you are
male actors a sword for the ax from the
other side which says you're well
prepared get on with it for me well we
like to address that John when it come
back to my concern yeah google it well
that I'm sure where we all beat it just
a minor point on that I understand that
that the point is being made
interestingly I think it's not clear
exactly what the government will do in
terms of actually seeking to impose an
arrangement of local authorities perhaps
a castle point might be in the frame if
they don't actually make progress on
their local plan but I mean I think what
was suggested the in fact was that it
wouldn't be CLG that we come in what the
what the what would be looked at with
the possibility of sending in a team
from from the the county council now
that may or may not be better
worse than the team from from CLG I have
it I think we wait to see what exactly
what the what the conclusions will be on
their on that but you know perhaps if
into the county council about my la look
more of a positive day look yes but even
greater risk in my opinion chairman
because you know the council council
does have a lot of influence over this
council thank you I think it's really
really important that we concentrate on
making sure that we get all our plans in
place because as John has rightly said
we're in a good place now we're in a
good place in because of what we have
done before and what we're trying to do
now we are ahead of the game and it's
very very important to stay that way but
our duty to cooperate not only with
other councils and for them to cooperate
with us is also going to be important
part of this process so I've personally
feel that you know what we are doing now
going forward is going to be very very
important but we are holding our line
what others do they are going to have to
come up with the right words thank you
right well the recommendation is that
the duty to operate topic paper 2017 as
attached at appendix a be noted to the
evidence as evidence and published on
the council's website okay okay thank
you very much all right moving on
everybody Nestle new local players
issues documents documents highway
baseline technical note 2017 its purpose
is really to establish a baseline across
the district of where the issues are
on the highway network and fairest on
Tuesday and I know all aware of where
these girls who haven't had it on film
at football so it will be used to inform
more detailed knowledge modeling of the
highway network its entirety at the next
stage this poisoning basement okay
John John Kiev general you know you're
not surprised that this one is attracted
a great deal of attention from me and
I'm sure it will attract a great deal of
attention from residents I'm sure they
will we'll look at this document and
bring their local knowledge to bear on
what's presented and what further trends
they are concerned about I note that the
paper talks about there being technical
modeling of traffic flows undertaken at
the next stage well of course that's
important I tell you what I fear
chairman I you know this will probably
be echoed in everyone's half here and
maybe echoed by what other people got to
say there were members of the committee
I I just see from what we've done so far
which is six years worth of development
with others sitting in the wings and I
constantly hear from residents saying
but I've got problems going to school
I've got problems going to work I've got
problems getting home from work I've got
problems at weekends in leisure and it
seems that any small incidents actually
cause you know absolutely huge problems
across the whole network well that's not
going to go away because
traffic users and their standard driving
I'm sure we'll continue the present
level or form or worse but if we're
embarking you know on a review which
looks as an additional seven and a half
thousand five figures of course on top
of what we've already planned which is
2785 that's lor that's that's that's
that's ten thousand and I you know I I
bought when I saw Bowser dunes bigger
but with her again dazzled in is a far
more economically important ice than
Rockford district being stuck as part of
the peninsula okay
my concern is this that this piecemeal
approach of Junction improvements even
even the invocation of the ceiling you
know something like four or five years
time isn't going to do what's going to
be necessary I was I was quite surprised
to find Android owners lauded on his
story I don't know it was a dream that's
what his name said on the TV has come up
with a view for all the the Oxford area
talking about a seven billion pound
necessary injection into infrastructure
to allow that important economic area to
function this is where we live is an
important economic area not necessarily
for what is generated in the district
itself but the people who live here and
generate the world in other towns and
cities cities being London cities being
jobs but cities being Colchester etc etc
I fear that we're just going to get a
technical study which is going to say
but it's alright but it isn't all right
it's not all right he really isn't
we need an Android bonus to take a few
of this part of the peninsula
including South Emperor as well it's
council point and do the same this is
the one where I expect our council our
county councillors to start pushing back
and challenging it's not that I be good
enough as we did last time to rely upon
Essex County Council's it will be all
right on the night cuz you know it no I
rest but I dressed that chair I figured
up because there are residents here
because I passionately believe in it and
I think there are members around this
table both visiting and them to the
committee who agreed with me but we've
got to start saying it but they think
John are going back many years was when
Asda opened in roars blame and their
assessment was there will be no
increasing no substantially increasing
traffic
my view was whiner the rest over the
store there if there's not going to be
any increase in traffic
that's the worst economic scenario you
could come in so I think well you know
from your experience we have tried
repeatedly to get this bigger approach
you know with a lot of development here
and now they look and development there
we're all I think we're all aware of
this Matthew over here you know some
comment on this no I mean we need to get
that balance you know if the housing the
infrastructure the jobs so that we get a
balanced approach and and this is just
the baseline this is a technical
starting point as it were this will
develop do you know the modelling work
that we're doing it's not isolated it's
just looking at this borough we're
looking to look at how our flows connect
with Southend in other areas as well so
this work will develop and start to
inform where those stress points are
where the issues are with the Junction's
and what may be able to do to relieve
this obviously you've quoted the 7,000
that's the the unconstrained approach
obviously you know the the target that
we have been in Rochford you know will
probably be very different to that but
we don't know what that is yet you know
we were very early in the process the
issue yes you know that all the talk
that's been about the the Oxford arc
this morning and the potential money
that's going to be invested in that it's
there the possibilities are there to
approach government and the
for structure Commission and their work
the only issue is with with that funding
comes a commitment from the local
authorities and across that arc I think
I may be wrong but I think the
government are looking for the of all
the authorities if they're going to have
that 7 billion to deliver a million
houses so you know there is there is
that other side to it that they you know
if you are going to get the additional
infrastructure government wants
something something out that money
you're putting in just just to say that
okay this new ones probably what I'm
gonna say is not news to people around
this table other people in this room but
this the geographical nature of the
district you know he's it takes the
traffic the water flows within the
district you know there is we're hedged
in on three sides so the traffic flows
re-of west to east and backwards and
along that that's your corridor also the
main main roads and routes are actually
outside of our boundaries so it's it's
key that we need to emphasize the
difficult situation that this district
in in relation to communication and make
sure that that is that is taken into
consideration
when when Essex County Council is
looking at future improvements and
beyond that and more strategically as
well because the people in the district
do find big because of the development
that's taken place over the last few
years an increasing problem in getting
around their area and we need to see
improvements in this yeah I don't think
there's anybody under any illusion knew
about the situation I mean one could
argue that planning in the past hasn't
been very productive
I've only been in in body since 1950 I
know
new roads have been created I can count
on one hand the number of new houses
have been created you know I think when
I moved here that was probably eight
thousand people and there were four cars
in my whole Road we've never got four
cars into houses and nothing's happened
so we we are going to be playing
catch-up I don't think any of us are
under any illusions we have tried
repeatedly to do this but we're gonna
have to you know work with closer with
the other parties because it is going to
become effectively it will become an
economic problem because people won't be
able to move around and businesses
either won't come here or they can't
generate you know this is this it so
very well having you know the big
terminal at Tilbury and all these sorts
of places but the knock-on effect if
nobody can move anywhere will be that
this area will stagnate and I don't
think that's what any of us any of us
one the recommendation committees that
the highways baseline technical note
2017 as a tax at Appendix A be noted has
ever done some published upon the
council's website we agreed thank you
right now are you ready okay moving on
to item number 13 the new local plan
issues not Kim options document gypsy
and traveler accommodation assessment
known as the GTA a 2017 Rockford distant
element over to you on the deef Egyptian
travel assist across the county this is
something that we have been doing as a
county for at least the last 10 years to
get a good picture of where our needs
are in the district
in the in the county and what they are
projected to be in the future
very simply the study funk we have a
baseline of 17 gypsy talent it is
already in the district the assessment
has slightly differently to be
successfully change the definition in
the planning policies travelers sites I
won't go into too much detail around
that members that were present at the
training of cheese day yeah
understanding of that now fully the
assessment identifies that as a need for
15 additional pitches for gypsum
travelers by those that do and don't
meet thee the new definition in the
National guidance and that's up to 2021
it's slightly different to what's
already in our strategy we don't need
you to the way that you need current
policies there 50 pitches five twenty
twenty one thirds by 2018 but our most
recently assess made sense that we need
to provide those pictures by okay they
cook don't go yeah
Massa we did give members of training a
more detailed view of the present
position on to travel the sites and the
changes in classification categorization
which I won't go back into but if
residents wanna contact me I'm quite
happy to share with them the information
that I have I guess that I'm concerned
because we there was recently an appeal
which suggested that plan against backs
actually wrote that the council hasn't
carried out its obligations under the
previous core strategy
2011 2025 in particularly deliver those
those pitches and is therefore allowed
pitches that we wouldn't ordinarily have
we may not have ordinarily have included
within our assessment and therefore
delivery what I don't quite understand
is we've got that we've got that
obligation for 15 by 2018 but we now
have an assessment we talks about that
being at a later date which takes
precedent which one are we gonna get I
mean this is only this is only in review
so 24 anyone doesn't apply does it so so
so yeah I mean I suppose the difficulty
is that sites are allocated for a
particular use as you say with some of
the industrial units and things like
that they don't get taken up and the
issue is with this allocated site for
one reason or another it hasn't come
forward which means that we still have
an outstanding need and the inspector I
think in that particular case took the
opinion that they didn't feel that that
site was going to come forward in the
short term
meant that they allowed this particular
site to come forward all sites are
judged on sort of an individual site by
site basis and as well as saying the
issue with Michelin's farm potentially
there are other issues of that site in
relation to I think it was that children
it was an individual family the previous
week about land and the neighbors gave a
positive review of them at the at the
hearing all those factors came together
on that site to make the inspect to make
that particular decision now obviously
you know a case-by-case basis
potentially not all cases are the same
but I guess while that site isn't taken
up you know it the potential I suppose
is there so that it's the delivery it's
the delivery issue but you know that's
not just sort of gypsy traveller pitches
it's the delivery of housing and other
medications that is really good it's our
obligation because it's in our core
strategy plan 2011 2035 but there are
always the plans that need to not just
help us deliver it but actually deliver
it and I certainly recall hearing
reading understanding that there's a
huge amount of money involved in
producing a site of that number size of
pitches properly appointed probably
controlled etc except et cetera
something around two million pounds I I
heard at one stage whether or not that's
right or indifferent I think I mean I've
seen it you know I think an inspector
commented so it must be right but then
we don't have that two million pound and
we don't have that obligate we don't
have that financial obligation so homes
that's down because at the moment we're
kind of exposed are we so we've got this
review which is great but it's not gonna
help us and this is practical this is
practical planning yeah practical and
spatial planners you know I guess it you
know it comes down
whether it's a housing site you know
market or a gypsum trap site it's being
deliverable you know suitable and all
those other potential incentives
well I suppose it's who is available to
help facilitate the delivery of that
site and at a moment no one has come
forward properly to come and deliver
that site for us so hence I guess during
the review we need to see whether that
site was the most appropriate site at
the moment it seems to be a very
difficult to deliver cycle yeah yeah you
wanna seem that as I understand it that
all the proposed pitches ruling that one
on site so this is the issue or the
problem of perhaps having all their eggs
in one basket because and this it may be
something that we need to consider
looking forward because if we if we REM
if the situation is that we reliant on
someone to bring this this site forward
for us to me air and need and it's
everything's just based on one side then
we we likely to have similar problems
going forward and so I mean what what
I'll add to that and that's what I was
going to say previously is again in the
referring back to the issues and options
document under the Gypsy and traveler
chapter there are a number of options to
put forward how we might deliver this
differently to how we did last time
bearing in mind what we've learned from
the previous you know approaching the
plan so it could be that we need small
sites you know that are deliverable and
and perhaps that's a easier way of
meeting that need but there's other
options involved as well as having a
criteria based approach you know it's
open at this moment for for the
community to put forward their thoughts
on how we should best meet this need
okay how we can to get silent this is
later chairman but how are we gonna get
to the to the traveler community in our
consultation because I don't just one up
personally
I don't just want our you know standard
residential dwellers as well that way of
Jeeves words not inflammatory and
certainly don't envy any from from from
from general residents but also how we
going to get to the we say gypsy but we
say travelers how we going to get to
them to get their views we practice and
we've done yes we all of the well the
vast majority of this in ships in terms
of the population of in the district
were interviewed doing preparation of
the GTA so we've already got that
engagement with them and certainly they
digits in some of the unit that's
provided by aesthetics they have broke
your engagement with the the communities
as well so there is a way we can get in
contact with them to to get their
thoughts on how we should be meeting
their needs
okay the distinct impression that we've
made better headway on this aspect than
most other areas and we yes okay because
as I understand it there is an intention
to have to science within Essex is there
any likelihood that that we are going to
be that certainly came out through the
2014 GTA it is an issue that we're
really looking again as a group of
authorities in Essex we there is some
information in the district tournament
in the full assessment there is a bit
more even more detail on how we should
press that we need to do more more work
basically on the place where they're
taking place and water actually means
for us where we should be providing
those that sort of transit permission
but we haven't reached as the winner six
which authoritative it's like okay okay
many members we have a recommendation
with this gentleman the merging GTA as
attached and Appendix A denoted evidence
and published on the council's website
okay thank you very much
moving on to item number fourteen new
local plan issues not humans document
infrastructure delivery topic paper 2017
okay yeah
[Applause]
so infrastructure as we discussed
earlier on in this is a key fact that we
need there is a quadrant we need to
clearly show how firstly the the abuse
judge that we need to support our
emerging plans and also how that's life
it's been delivered and best practices
through specific documents and
infrastructure delivery plan which sits
alongside draft local and
because of these damaged brush with
reviewing our existing local hometown
we're not in a position to give a clear
indication what it was judge may be
needed over the next 15 20 years so what
we have done to support the creation of
your options document on its publication
is the preparation of very specific
topic paper on infrastructure delivery
broadly setting out who we will need to
be engaging with and also what our
current baseline is base my position is
in terms of infrastructure needs and
delivery to date okay any questions on
this I think you know we pretty much
hammered the infrastructure needs of an
area that we're all very concerned about
and I think we can at least it can be
one of the the big issues that we're
gonna have to address absolutely into
something that we will be working on
this as we as we go through next time
but slightly so it will evolve it will
change it will have whatever
infrastructure requirements I like to be
and how there
okay thank you John
would it be helpful with the council
seniors helpful the committee see it is
helpful for residents to comment on what
they see the current infrastructure
deficits are yes as part of the issues
and oceans consultation yes because they
are issues so absolutely yeah okay yeah
we think yeah yeah go in just add I
think one of the things that have let
down call support Basildon and Brentwood
has has been the infrastructure issues
in not being able to bring their plans
forward and I think that's a
contributing issue and when we have to
look very seriously at infrastructure
because if we can't get the
infrastructure right then nothing else
could be delivered and that's that is
that is the main issue without
infrastructure we can't deliver anything
thank you I'll say yeah simple as like
the recommendation is that the
infrastructure delivery topic paper 2017
is attached at pendeks a if you notice
evidence and published on the council's
website interjected at that point you
know something a little catchphrase
which I'm I've heard it's not mine
there's nothing to do you read Bruce
Forsyth either I can assure you but you
know does this committee agree with the
infrastructure first I think I don't
think these infrastructure thirst I
think you have to coordinate the whole
approach I don't think you can just take
this in isolation now this is this is
just a whole consultation document and
everything is basically got to be put
into it I don't think you can just say I
might be wrong
don't know Matthew but you've got a
you've got to put everything in this
together infrastructures is a critical
part but then so is the houses and so is
the employment I don't think you can
break them up for infrastructure but
they adapt John we all agree because
we've discussed if nothing can move
around if all the other bits and pieces
don't work the rest of it falls apart
and just to emphasize something I think
that you've said earlier is that
historically infrastructure in this
district has lagged behind or even
non-existent
yeah I mean I don't you say that you
know it's that sustainable balance again
about the class infrastructure and
housing and yes you know that there will
be sites and allocations where there
will need to be pumped Prime you know
infrastructure transport infrastructure
whatever that is you know education
health whatever needs to come in to
support a new development a new a new
community whatever it is coming in so
yeah I'm glad you said that because
we've got an absolute classic in in
Hopley and Hopewell where we've got a
school that needs to need to expand
because the education Authority tells us
that it's through the additional houses
that have been built and yet being a
very very conscientious ward member when
the development team model the large
development of my award was contemplated
at this stage in the last plan mrs.
county councillor shortly there was no
need for additional school places so
that's why I said and that's why I say
this is Kansas this committee agree with
infrastructure first because you know
here we are we the houses have been
built and now the school finds itself in
a position where it doesn't have enough
space so I'm hugely confused I think
you're aware John that there are certain
areas that this district does not have
control over and that is one of them
here
it's counter counts are now saying
infrastructure first oh good good guys
just put me in their maker I think it's
important that we as a council we might
have stronger arguments for what we need
section 106 or SIL when it comes along
in regards to all the various
infrastructure that is needed when any
any development goes on we make those
strong arguments for need to go with it
ok ok we have the recommendation which I
read out earlier ok thank you very much
and the last aspect of these evidential
reports is the new local issues and
options document grow on space
feasibility study 2016
quickly at the need for growers like
across the county and only it found that
Watchers has a real need for big
choppiness
we have a very entrepreneurial culture
and lot starting to and there just isn't
the spice which makes meets the name of
those businesses to actually expand and
grow here okay any questions on this one
designer chair yeah good we got to do it
right yeah okay the recommendation is
that the girl and space feasibility
study 2016 as a taste at Appendix A we
notice that this evidence and published
on the council's website thank you right
I think that's brought us up to all the
evidential documentation that we needed
to go through I'll now move on to won't
do them together or take the six points
and she didn't separate ok we'll go to
item number six name which is the new
local plan issues not options document
Joff consultation document draft
sustainability appraisal and the
consultation and engagement summary 2017
mr. Tomasson yeah I guess it's been
quite useful that we've actually taken
it in the order we have because the
evidence-based documents that we've all
sort of discussed and gone through and a
lot of the points of actually sort of
being made that are probably pertinent
and of interest in the issues and
options document itself this is the
first stage of review of the planning
documents have being adopted by Rockford
over since since 2011 there were a
couple of error action plans and site
locations in 2015 as well as a
development management document so this
is this is the first stage of Statuary
public consultation on this document at
this stage there is no policy in the
plan at this moment it is as the title
says looking at issues and options now
the evidence base that has being
discussed today the chapter headings in
choose an options document you know
relate very much so - the topic papers
and the evidence-based reports that
we've been discussing at the moment as I
say there's no policy because we want to
hear the views of the community this is
interested parties infrastructure
providers all those who should make a
contribution to this document at this
stage so that we can start to put
together the representations made on
this plan to take it forward to the next
stage after this this document we're
looking if if it's agreed to go out to
consultation as we mentioned for a
12-week period which would start we're
looking probably in in mid-december at
that date so then it will run for a
12-week period normally they only run
for a six four six week is the minimum
period so we are doing double the
minimum period of consultation on this
document at this stage it's an
accompanied by what's known as a
sustainability appraisal which evaluates
the economic social and environmental
factors related to the document as it's
such an early stage it's difficult for
the sustainability appraisal to make
more than sort of general comment on the
plan once there's policies in place then
the this sustainability appraisal can
make recommendations to that plan to
ensure that it meets those three main
factors of what planning is meant to
deliver to the delivers sustainable
development and sustainable communities
that is out for consultation with the
issues in options document in addition
to that we have a consultation and
engagement summary which outlines the
type of public engagement that's going
to take place over the 12-week period of
the plan and that you know has to comply
with our statement of community
involvement which shows how we are going
to consult the community in our plans
and strategies and also as far as
development controlling development
is concerned so really everything that
we've discussed all the chats in there
we would be encouraging the community to
engage in this process and put
representations in on chapters and areas
of the issues and options document that
they feel strongly about there is an
executive summary that's included which
hopefully gives a flavor of what's in
the document but we have stated in that
executive summary we really need people
to go to the chapters that they're very
interested in and make comments on those
chapters so okay I'm sure there'd be
some quick well the officers will know
that I'm going to come back on the
things that I promised last Tuesday and
I can't find anything in here that tells
me that the trajectory date for the
quantum is 2037 I think that's an
important thing to include within this
draft consultation I also believe that
the unconstrained our way in figure
taking into account shortfalls from 2011
relation back to 2014 going forward to
2030 seven should be declared so that
residents have a perspective upon what
the unconstraint figure is my my own
calculations a little bit of rounding in
seven and a half thousand I would like
to see the officers do a do a proper
calculation explain it to me and other
members in time to inform council so
that we can improve that into the
document you want to take that first I
think they were expecting that one June
thank you those quick press and take the
point about the plan period we do have
it on the vision section but we can make
that more explicit elsewhere that's a no
problem and as promised at the the
training session we have done a little
bit of work the the oen taking account
of shortfall and we do have some options
which I'm not gonna ambush is there yeah
I mean I if I just make a note here
realistically what John has said is on
the term unconstrained yet and I think
that is a very very important term that
needs to be noted by you know the
committee and and members of the public
in general they are unconstrained
figures there will be constraints
infrastructure lots of other items which
will have to be taken into consideration
when we eventually go to inspection so
those are the upper figures but
constraints will obviously change those
figures do you want to go and do all I
can say is I was remarkably accurate by
hitting a midline figure at seven half
thousand it yeah so you know I'll take
great credit in my own work been a great
book
I think as is as as is in the state this
this hopefully is the biggest bigger
than the unconstraint figure it's up for
us and our officers to do our homework
and do our job and make sure that we try
and make sure we can put a supportable
case together that that figure isn't
unconstrained it is reduced
substantially and and just just to
reiterate exactly what you said this
this is the the objectively assess need
figure is normally referred to in the
NPP F the National Planning policy
framework as the starting point so it's
the starting point before those
potential discounting measures come in
you know relate to environmental
constraints etc etc so yes I mean I
think I know members are aware but the
government is looking at the öin formula
methodology and I have read about
councils you know having regard to two
types of figure one which is calculated
on this current basis which is in the
shmeil I won't Lucido T if you really
want to go to sleep do start reading it
early in the evening but there is the
expectation that this will be the mill
Authority will be revised and it will
include some assessments that other
councils have already used on occasion
and that is the economic ambition and
needs of of the districts and I know
that council appointment because I read
theirs
Abid Lee seed include within their own
assessments and I can't remember don't
be astonished mobbing it was a separate
sentence Alton I do remember that
actually did it did actually have quite
ambitious plans for economic development
and because those plans for economic
development were were ambitious and I
think too ambitious that brought with it
an increased number of dwellings to the
baseline if you like unconstrained Oh a
in are we in that situation do we expect
the government to change that formula
and do we expect it to be predicated on
a ambition assessment for economic
development I'm gonna face at this stage
we need to go with the best available
evidence and that's the adopted and
existing or published documents that we
have yes the government are reviewing
the methodology and they have put out
some draft figures for authorities you
know in relation to how a standard
methodology might result in a different
housing need for authorities at the
moment obviously that look that isn't
adopted as such by government as a
standard methodology it's likely to come
in next year I think for us it in our
range it includes an additional home
isn't it it's 362 so it's an additional
home per year according to the standard
methodology of unconstrained just just
to reiterate that to everyone like that
isn't a target so at this stage we need
to go with the best available evidence
obviously at the moment it's an issues
and options document next year when we
look at going to the next stage that
standard methodology may be agreed
published then we have to look at how
that fits into the evidence basis we
take the document forward but at the
moment a planning inspector would say
that you have to go with the best
available hours a very limited
difference between what's in the current
smart assessment and what the standard
method
would apply but as I say we need to take
that at the time when it is the official
approach can you just help me to
understand what I did see in that castle
point document because it was produced
by external consultants and I did read
it quite carefully and there was a
section in there which was about the
economic ambition that the counsellor
had for the area and indeed create a
significant change to the sort of
household number review the d c-- OG was
then putting forward i mean i think that
particular doctrine I think was
producing 2014 so it was superseded by
the Sh mark and thus more addendum but
just to go into that obviously if if
authorities and government were said if
authorities are looking to be ambitious
as such with their jobs numbers then
they have to factor in that they needs
to be an increase to housing to support
those job numbers so they kind of go
hand in hand I guess which would have
potentially come out of that report that
you were looking at at the time of
production which was then superseded by
the small which takes into account for
all the authorities in South Essex the
economic uplift as such from the
assumptions made so ok so my conclusion
as much as I was you but to also say
well obviously in our evidence that
we've accepted and will be put forward
there there is economic assessments and
evidence that is a weak we agreed was
somewhat in its I'll say infancy that's
not quite the right word but early stage
if you like and therefore that can
actually drive higher figures there's as
I say there is potential because of how
ambitious you are with your jobs and
what you want to come into the district
there is a balance to be set between
jobs and houses yes thank you I'm okay
now and I and I hope members remember
that
because the more ambitious we are
economically and there's nothing wrong
with that then it may well drag housing
numbers with it John said with regard to
the building's problem across the points
assessment and their ambition they
wanted their vision and they wanted
everybody else in the surrounding areas
to fulfill their duty and I think I
think that that was a major issue that
affected us all and the duty to
cooperate that didn't exist okay thank
you any more it Neil go we've got a
number of sites and areas within our
district which you've got environmental
protection on them for various different
wildlife reason yeah I'm just wondering
how robust are those designations and
protections in relation to this process
and are we as part of this process are
we going to be investigating and looking
at other areas that might need to have
designations that might protect those
areas as well one of the reasons why I
bring this up is is in relation to a
recent relatively recent story about a
development that took place in our
region where a site receive planning
permission which was directly next to a
protected site and it didn't seem that
the impact on that right on the boundary
of that that designated site was taken
into consideration so I just wonder how
that fits for the process
the application of your authority but
from a from a policy perspective there
are a number of international European
invention of national designations that
being a coastal authority they apply to
apply to us the only local designations
we have at the moment are local wildlife
sights and hope these members are aware
we are going through a review process of
that because then our assessment is now
a lot of previous assessment is now 10
years old
and look obviously you can change you by
by diversity times biodiversity over
that time what we have on staff is
something to do as part that is to
engage with the the wildlife charges
such as sea as its wildlife trust to
identify any other potential sites which
may have some value that we should be
assessing and considering so that
assessment is hopefully going to be
published next year but it should
provide an update on where I locally
controlled life sites so effectively
what what is there now may not may be
increased upon yeah potentially in you
know I think one of the other things is
to recognize the importance that a large
agricultural industry has it's the
largest in the Thames gateway and and we
have to make sure that we looked at what
impact and what necessity we need when
we do our appraisals with regard to
things regarding agriculture okay John
can we move on I'll be allowed in this
section I'm not sure we've got the
statement of community involvement as
part of this you know paper on the
agenda to include this in this one or
the consultation engagement summary is
that we call it yes okay things keep
changing oh no only because we really
Joe it's just the elements of the
statement that have been taken forward
foot for this my name - yeah it goes
okay and Jenna know there are a few
things that that bothered me as part of
that we
words like endeavour crept in
words like may do this crept in snow I
don't like that either I think it's time
if we're engaging with residents to make
it absolutely clear you know what we are
going to do is not an endeavor are we
going to do it we are going to do it so
take the endeavor out of words
take the may and we may do this because
you know we should be engaging from the
middle of December so that's that's a
criticism but nevertheless there is
various there is fairly criticism from
from me because I recall that for
council we secured a leaflet budget of
fifteen thousand pounds if I remember
rightly and at this council lovely and I
remember that and we did not even make
them is good so when I read that we
might we may give out some leaflets at
railway stations
I actually thought hey that's not good
enough because the 15,000 pounds and I
do is have some experience of
leafletting we can leave every house in
our district and there are people who
are already commenting on social media
talking about when the survey comes
through my door I will do this well if
it's not going to come through their
door they're not going to do it so the
expectation is and my expectation is on
an engagement bearing in mind weekend
lot for district matters and there's a
lot of people who actually said I don't
think what's been mattered at all but
nevertheless it was there it's not so I
would like the the subcommittee to agree
with me that we should be putting
leaflets through everyone's door using
the budget that we've that we put aside
yeah I have to say that it was that
meeting of the full council was probably
prior to my engagement I'm sorry
and so I'm not aware of whether that
budget was committed or it was I suppose
you know
commenting from the outside from
experience elsewhere
yes you know that that's an approach
whether whether that is the best way to
sort of commit that type of fun to it to
engage to the full extent of the
community I don't know it's open to see
if that would be the case you know all
of us around this table have a lot of
experiences solved of leave lives and we
have a great deal of understanding about
the impacts of leaflets on residents
activity as battering and we we know we
know that leafleting gets people out to
do things yeah I want this I want this
first consultation to be a Barnstormer
we've said this from the very beginning
all of us on the subcommittee we want
the highest engagement possible yeah my
experience tells me from 17 it's long as
much longer than that
17 years as a member yes alone the
previous 14 years as a resident
association chairman the leaflets are
the are the most impacting we can do to
getting data so I recommend it strongly
yeah also chairman we didn't do very
well last time you you've acknowledged
that in committee yourself we didn't do
well last time and we ended up we ended
up in a review at the high court I don't
want to see us ending up in a review at
the high court for any reason and
notwithstanding what they are come my
feet to avoid that I recommend I ask
that we lived it and we leaflet every
single consultation we do
I don't anyone to say to me I did not
know about this okay in well I think
that's is vitally important we cannot
have any excuse out there ever again
that people said I didn't know about
anything I do realize that I have had
feedback where leaflets were put in the
door and even so those people still
didn't know either because they went out
with the rubbish well there's a sling on
the way but we have to do our best we
are not going to fundamentally be a
hundred percent accurate I've got to
accept that but we need to get as higher
and accuracy within our district as we
possibly can so we have to use every
single means at our disposal through
parishes through leafleting to make
awareness through libraries through any
other means we can local local churches
whatever it takes to ensure that as many
people as possible
within this district and even the
simplicity of word of mouth word of
mouth is very very important for people
to pass on to each other
have you seen do you know this is
happening you need to take part we need
your input into it and I think that's
vitally important
so initially fleeting I'm very much
looking can we say then in your capacity
its portfolio holder in conjunction with
Nathalie and Matthew you will we will
look at those mains diem efforts yes
thank you Jim yeah I think there's in
seat two to just say we put and we put
in this information on our website and
it's available but that's a very passive
engagement you know this we need I think
with this process we need to be much
more active and and and why I actually
go down and having something go through
everyone
door is a much more active way of
engagement the other the other thing in
relation to things like information on
and council websites is that there's a
potential that that disadvantages
certain sections about community
especially those that don't have the
facility or wave or option of accessing
that information so even councilor Mason
has difficulty in accessing with some
some electronic information sometimes
value infrastructure problems tonight
members if if I can just say we'd have
three recommendations here on this topic
could we add a fourth one in and I mean
we can't make the decisions here as
you're as you're aware we make the
recommendation to full council that
leafleting to all properties be
incorporated in this consultation
process we we submit that as their pub
item number four on these
recommendations to fall Council and we
did hear from the portfolio yeah which i
think is very important to have as part
about the recommendation here I
appreciate what you said what you've
done yes hello I'd like to call council
to know well beforehand what your views
are yep so can can we take it sorry too
kind of a step further when that
consultation is then responded to by
residents and we hope it's going to be
many more and that's the whole point of
access but everyone usable thoughtfully
editing as I understand it from what we
have in front of us that the responses
from that will feed into the options
document which will then be available
bring 980 yeah I mean what basically
will happen at the next stage is that
from the representations received that
updates the evidence base everything
feeds into the next version of the
document the preferred options document
but the council will form a schedule to
the representations made and an officer
responds to that so that will be made
available as well so we have three
recommendations currently on on the
table which are actually while you're
thinking about that I'd commend our
officers or what I consider to be the
most readable planning consultation I
have seen this council produce it is
rare for me to give praise but we give
praise where it's tube they cook I'm
very impressed with the approach that's
been taken it's too long said certain
that early language I agree with them
and nevertheless it is what it is and
it's very readable for thank you which
is coming as well your chair one of the
things that was presented to members on
the training was a very very good
overview of what we're actually looking
at and I'm going to be discussing with
without offices both mentally and in
regards to maybe doing some form of
video editing which would type that for
magic with also voiceover to explain and
go through so it will be open to the
wider public to be able to fully
understand
and comprehend the depth in a simple way
so that they understand the mechanisms
that we're going through and how we're
trying to accomplish what fundamentally
is an extremely difficult task but we're
hoping that with the help of the public
they will be able to input the concerns
they have generally in their area we can
type those into considerations with
regard to the constraints but how most
importantly their wish list that's the
that's the thing that we always went
around they've all got a wish list of
things that they want to see happening
and finally to make those plain at the
earliest moment so that we can put them
into the plans and understand whether
they're deliverable or not and how we
will deliver them and just to reiterate
again yes those those sections that are
in the issues and options document we'd
encourage people to go to those sections
that you know most of interest to them
and pertinent to them and put their
representations in on that so we've got
a fifth we've got a video channel we're
looking at something we're discussing on
the viability and doing it to get it on
the website too to other aspects we've
got here the documents of hope you've
just been given it it's suggested that
the first paragraph and the first table
be included in the issues and operas
document before paragraph six point ten
and the three recommendations that we
currently have which is that draft
issues an option document and
accompanying interim sustainable
appraisal as attached Appendix A E and B
respectively be published for formal
public consultation for up to twelve
weeks that the sustainable appraisal
scoping report as a text as Appendix C
be noted as evidence and published on
the council's website and item three
that the activities set out in the
consultation engagement summary has a
text at appendix d be noted and
published on the
website and that we put a fourth
recommendation in is that all properties
within the district we leave with it
with an option stating the consultation
process is this thing yes because and I
want somebody saying you've got to find
more money we haven't got it now sir
yeah no okay are we agreed with that
fine thank you very much and last but
not least item number seven Matthew -
yeah the last one is just is quite
simple it's just a update to the local
tournament scheme time table just to
reflect the fact that we've adjusted the
timeframes to where that the
consultation is taking place this
consultation and then the knock-on
effect on future stages of the plan
making process okay have we got any any
questions go fine I said I'd come back
to this the very beginning as I said
earlier my mind here is there it's
absolutely vital that the evidence is
considered carefully in depth as widely
as we can certainly by counselors and
challenges made to every organization
that submits to it if we do we are not
content and we're certainly not content
as members with what proposals are put
forward particularly around
infrastructure so I'd say 2021 ok but if
we need longer because that process is
going to take longer there's no need to
rush we are not under pressure from any
part of government to do that I don't
want to find ourselves in a position
having to say but we had to do it
because of the time scale because of our
project plan I'm quite prepared to make
that two years longer if necessary to
get the result that we need and and
residents deserve
truly passionate good I mean yeah and
adjustments can always be makes the
development scheme to represent that
because I think what we need to do when
we get to examination is have a robust
and defensible plan that meets the needs
of the community so and hopefully you
government-centric of them don't join
the pro change Adolfo's gonna be my
point you know yeah if that does happen
then that my dupe train I'm angry but I
think you know our glide says it's tough
yeah item number six seven then it is
recommended that the revised LDS local
government scheme as a test in Appendix
A be adopted okay thank you can I just
thank you for your attendance here today
thank committee and they are
particularly the officers for their
presentation I hope that you have some
confidence in us that we will try and do
the best we can for our residents we are
all residents here and we will do our
best to protect but at the same time
develop our district thank you very much
meeting closed at 11:45 thank you